[Music]
joining me today is an author a
columnist and the rabbi of Sinai Temple
right here in Los Angeles Rabbi David
Wolpe welcome to the Reuben report thank
you I feel like we've already spent 45
minutes together
sorry I've now I'm gonna have to repeat
everything okay I actually didn't tell
you the truth about my opinions up to
this point so it's fine right a little
bait-and-switch oh that's right all
right that's it all right so there's a
lot I want to talk to you about okay
it's Monday right now it's yeah it's
about Monday or Tuesday what the news
day it's Tuesday see I didn't tell you
the truth about that either so it's
Tuesday afternoon what does a rabbi
normally do around three o'clock on a
Tuesday afternoon normally I have
meetings I've meetings with staff I have
meetings with congregants for advice for
counsel for I meet with various
charities I mean with Bar Mitzvah kids I
meet with wedding couples
um I write I teach weddings funerals all
those sorts of things yeah so you're
sort of on call all the time sure yeah I
have hours to the rabbi have hours you
have hours where you meet with people
but you don't necessarily I mean is
somebody sick in the hospital you don't
say I'm sorry I can't see you it's you
know it's not a good time right but you
have hours where you have essentially
office hours where you make set meetings
yeah so I thought a good jumping-off
point for us would be that I saw that
Newsweek called you one of the 50 most
influential Jews yes so the question is
were you above or below Larry Dave
so that was Jerusalem Post actually did
that who wouldn't Newsweek called me the
one for about seven or eight years
Newsweek strangely judged the most
influential rabbis in America so one of
the years I was the most influential
rabbi in America which means that I
really hit the sweet spot because in the
thousands of years of Jewish history for
seven years they ranked rabbi ranking
rabbis what I mean is they got three
people who said okay this is number one
this is number two so you can't take
these things too seriously
right
and and and influence is a very
amorphous thing and no I'm not as
influential as larry day that is it
Larry for it or nearly as funny or
creative okay but for the record that
was the Jerusalem Post yes and not
Newsweek all right but the reason I
wanted to start with that question was
because I think at least sort of in my
world most of the Jews that I'm around
more a lot of Jews I'm Jewish that there
is a cultural attachment to Judaism
that's separate sort of from the
religious varieties of Judaism
that's a rabbi that's probably not the
thing that you want to hear first but
that does seem to me what sort of the
average secular Jewish it's and this is
one of the things that separates Judaism
from Christianity that I think most
Christians and many Jews don't
appreciate which is Christianity as a
religion if you believe in Jesus you're
Christian if you don't believe in Jesus
you're not Christian Judaism is a
religious family so you're born Jewish
the only way to leave a family is to
choose another family but as long as you
don't choose another family
you can dislike your family many of us
do right they're still part of the
family
so Jews have this very close connection
now these two systems they each have
advantages and disadvantages the
advantage of having a religion is it's
much more easily spread because if you
have somebody with a completely
different culture who says I believe in
Jesus they're Christian like you are the
advantage of having a religious family
is Jews feel a powerful sense of
connection to one another and that's why
when Jews are in trouble in a far-flung
land you can be sure that there will be
a Jewish rescue attempt you can be sure
of it because you steal that familial
connection in a way that Christians
don't do you do you think there's some
sort of risk in in separating the
religious side and that familial side
that heritage side well I for me I don't
think you I don't think Judaism can
survive as a cultural phenomenon without
religion I mean it's what we'll Herbert
called cut flower ethics that if you
remove flowers from the soil in which
they grew they'll last for a generation
or two but then they'll disappear
and I think the same thing will happen
with Judaism over time without the
religious roots that nourish it it will
eventually disappear yeah so what is it
about Judaism that has allowed so much
secularism and so much science and
thinking and learning and education all
of the things that for people that don't
like religion caste religion always
tells you what to think and religion
hate science and all of those things but
if you look at you know the hundred
greatest scientists of all time half of
them are usually Jews or something
so part of it is that Judaism has a
fierce intellectual tradition if you and
if you study Talmud there are arguments
on every single page and and that
tradition of argumentation was always
true and status was given to intellect
that is it's not that wealth didn't have
status in the Jewish tradition it did
like every other society but you want it
to be you want it to marry the rabbi I
mean that was he was the leader of the
community and he had the social status
and you became a rabbi by knowing more
really it was a knowledge competition
more than anything else and when you
have that fact sort of intellectual
tradition once you liberate it from
being solely a religious one you get
these trained intellects that look
around the world and and hungrily became
experts not just in science in medicine
in music and mathematics in chess I used
to be a tournament chess player it's
astonishing how many of the world
champions of chess have been Jewish and
it's all the same I think it's all the
same cultural tradition yeah do you see
sort of a chasm between all that
scientific knowledge and that
mathematical knowledge and all that and
then sort of the that you have to take a
leap of faith to believe in God which is
sort of the reverse of what science
would I found one of the reverses I
actually don't think it's the reverse I
mean I understand how people could see
it that way and some do see it that way
but I I think that the more you know
about the world and the more you
appreciate the wonder of the world and
sort of the iron laws of nature the more
you almost feel like what Robert Jastrow
the physicist said he says as as the
physicist peers over the horizon he
he feels like he sees that God who knew
we were coming but why does the world
have such laws why does it obey such
laws what created a system that we could
figure out and why is it that we have
minds that presumably were just
jerry-rigged by evolution right there's
no reason why our mind should be able to
figure out these things and yet we're in
consonance with the universe I mean I
think that the idea that there is a
designer as science presumes there's a
design makes perfect sense so I'm sure
as a rabbi in LA you probably have a lot
of skeptics in your community I got a
few you know you probably got a couple
80s in there some agnostics and all that
generally those people are not they're
not thought of as apostates or no you
know said they're still part of the
family right how do you have that
conversation with them we're just - have
you ever had you know someone coffee
I just don't know sure all the time and
some of my books actually address
exactly that in and as you know and as
we talked about I've had debates with
with a bunch with Christopher Hitchens
and Sam Harris and Richard Dawkins and
on all these very articulate and and
well-spoken atheists I really do think
that a lot of this is your orientation
towards the world and it's not so much
it's not so much an intellectual
decision in the sense that when I teach
Jewish theology and I've taught it for
many years at a bunch of different
universities so I've put up all the
classical Western proofs for God the
teleological proof in the cosmological
I've never had someone look at the board
ago oh now I believe this right because
even though we pretend it's a purely
intellectual argument it's not and you
can see that when you see how emotional
people become a theists or believers
when they start to argue this it's
really deep in us this orientation
towards the universe so I think that the
best argument for religion is to be in a
religious community for a while and see
how it helps you see the world
differently yeah so when you talk about
a religious community let break down
some of the okay different religious
communities but somebody that's watching
that has no idea what's going on with
those crazy Jews yeah what the basic
three that at least we had a bigger
the big three in the bathroom got a
reform conservative s an Orthodox can
you just sort of breakdown the Bayshore
by the way I do want to point out that
you said to me right before he said no
question is off the table that's true I
don't know what kind as I believe maybe
gave you something ah that's alright so
I've gotten to my I've got myself into
enough trouble already
well yes already here and he said no no
no no no it may be in in life yeah um so
the first first of all orthodoxy now I'm
going to give you not my perspective on
them but their self definition okay
orthodoxy self definition is that it
believes it is true to the Torah that
God gave Moses at Sinai thousands of
years ago and the authoritative
interpretations of the rabbi's of that
Torah which essentially are untouched by
history they're really they live above
history and and so the decision of the
authoritative rabbi today was in some
sense either literally known to or in
theory known to Moses thousands of years
ago that's worth a toxic yeah okay but
for the literal part yes
so these words art and the words in the
Torah are literally what God spoke maybe
God didn't speak the way I speak right
it doesn't have to be literally doesn't
mean literally a literal interpretation
tended Moses to have in the Torah
thousands of years ago
okay the conservative movement assumes
that the tradition grows and changes
that it is decided essentially by the
community of devoted Jews that that
community grows and changes to and that
history has a very profound impact in
the way that people see themselves their
community and that therefore the Torah
has to constantly be subject to the
interpretation that takes into account
what we know about the world that our
ancestors did not know there were four
movement places its emphasis primarily
on individual choice and individual
liberty also tends to have a strong
social justice and progressive political
orientation yeah how that must be the
most difficult part of being
rabbi or any clergy member what's the
political part that you see is wrong
rust into politics Tom right it's hard
to define the most difficult part but it
is a difficult part because my and some
rabbis are very political my own
orientation is to be as little political
as is possible which doesn't mean not at
all but my assumption is twofold first
of all there are people in my
congregation who know as much about
politics as I do so for me to get up
there and preach to them because I read
an article this morning is is hubristic
and presumptuous or as we would say quit
spitting yeah the second is that I know
very well that you can look at the
Jewish tradition and say Judaism says
and come out with a very right-wing
agenda or a very left-wing agenda and
both of them will have lots of verses
and lots of rabbis to quote and so when
people presume that Judaism speaks in
either a right or a left voice I think
they're they're wearing blinders what do
you make of the state of Jews in America
in 2017 there's always an article every
year the Judaism Judaism is over there
and done that the other thing they would
over as wise I guess it's not great it's
not there was a there was a professor at
Brandeis a philosopher many years ago
named Simon rather Dulwich and he wrote
an essay called Israel the ever dying
people and he quotes Jews in every
generation can say we're the last after
us there aren't going to be any more I'm
an optimist by me or I'm hopeful by
nature let me put it that way so I
presume that Judaism is going to a an
interesting sometimes painful
transformation what it will be in a
hundred years I don't know what I do
know is that no one would have predicted
a hundred years ago where we are now so
I try to stay out of the profit business
because I see that people would look I
watch Sunday morning talk shows and here
are presumably the best inform convicts
in the world and they're wrong at least
fifty percent of the time yeah so for me
to presume that this thousands of year
old tradition in this
complex land I know what will happen
especially because I'm aware that what
will happen to Jews in America has more
to do with what will happen to America
the moat will happen to Jews if you had
said to a Jew in Germany what's what's
Judaism in Germany going to be like in
50 years in the year 1900 they would
have looked at the Jewish community and
been completely wrong so a lot of it is
sometimes there's returns to tradition
there's a systolic diastolic movement I
assume Judaism will survive and what
exactly I don't know yeah I can already
tell we're good we're going to kind of
bounce all over the place while we're
doing this you mentioned Mount Sinai
book like it
that's where Moses got the Ten
Commandments according to the to the
lore I went to Mount Sinai in 1997 I was
21 years old I went through Egypt I went
I went from Israel actually through
through Sinai was a lot safer at the
time yes was I'm like a overnight bus
ride and I made it to the Sinai and
you're supposed to hike it they tell you
to hike it's something out like midnight
so that it's cool right by the time you
get to the top it's sunny I got there
like 8:00 a.m. and I ended up hiking in
the middle of the day I had just eaten
some pigeon in Cairo and I was it was
the best it was enough to put it mildly
I got to the top of Mount Ida the first
time someone told me a story about
having bad pigeon but you didn't and
Edward but I got the time that I truly
remember thinking this that if if God
exists that I will get some sort of sign
right that Moses saw the Ten
Commandments here I'm gonna get some
kind of sign I got up there and it's
pretty have you been there but yeah yeah
that's pretty barren there's a little
there's a guy that actually works there
and he sells water and so that's it and
there were like two other people and
they were quibbling over saying and I
looked around and they were no bushes
there were some twigs and things and you
know nothing happened and I realized
that that is only sort of stuck with me
like I was ready for it I was 21
yes there's an Amsterdam for two weeks
before that doing god-knows-what maybe
that's where you got the sign I probably
have a sign an answer and very possibly
but put that experience I do understand
it sort map recording before so I I
think part of it is that the moments of
illumination sometimes come
you in at times that you're not looking
for them unaware and if you think back
over your life and you think of moments
where for example you intensely
connected with another human being or
where you felt inspired by the beauty
and the wonder of the world for no
reason other than you were inspired by
the beauty in the wonder of the world
what I would say to you is that's a sign
I moment it may not have happened at
Sinai and may have happened you know I
don't know may happen in Simi Valley but
but it's a Sinai moment and and fidelity
to the moment is more important than
fidelity to the place
Soumya is actually very similar addition
I that's right exactly yeah that was
slick that is pretty similar so the
battle I think between sort of religion
and the cultural part of Judaism I is
this do you think this can sort of be
reconciled I think that there will
always be people who love being Jewish
but don't have a religious orientation
or religious feeling and and that's I
mean and many of them will make
fantastic contributions both by the way
to the world but also sometimes to
Judaism I mean Theodor Herzl was not a
religious Jew but he made an
unparalleled contribution to the Jewish
people into the Jewish tradition so it's
complicated and I and I am I am as as
you've probably already intuited I'm
really not a bright line person I'm not
like this is the way you have to be and
if you're not this way then you're
outside of the ambit of what's
acceptable because I just I think the
world is awash with gray yeah but is
that right they're sort of uniquely
Jewish that concept that a rabbi would
sit across from me and say that I'm sure
I find a priest that would say yeah sure
and you can find a lot of rabbis who
won't say it yeah I think I could
probably find a lot more rabbis that my
creation that might be and one of the
reasons again this is at least part of
the Talmudic tradition there is a
there's a statement there's a there's an
impure animal it's called a share it
means a lizard basically
and in the Talmud it says that somebody
who can't give you 70 reasons why this
impure animal is pure shouldn't be a
rabbi but as if you can't argue the
contrary of what it is you know to be
true then you don't have the
intellectual agility to be a rabbi which
means that you are trained in some sense
to see both sides and and if you if you
have an empathetic heart then you
realize that it's pretty rare that
something is so clearly black and white
that you can't imagine the other side
now there are such things obviously and
even things where you can't imagine the
other side doesn't mean that you don't
sometimes condemn them but but I always
I always assume that that you that life
is richer and and the human experience
is more elevated if you can manage to
get at least a scintilla of
understanding of what the person across
from you thinks yeah so when you see
someone like like a Larry David or a
science out or somebody I can bring
almost anything back to read calm space
good when you see them sort of offering
that version as of juice sort of like
you know New York or LA ultra-liberal
yes you know sort of a religious but
there's a cultural affinity or Larry to
in Curb Your Enthusiasm right he sort of
has an absolute aversion to religion and
all that do you see that as a is it a
net good because he's putting some sort
of Jewish ideas out there or do you see
it as well he there's a what despair of
religion or just his take on what
bothers me about it is the ignorance of
it because here you have a tradition of
thousands of years of devotion and
brilliance and exploration of life and
meaning and it's reduced to a joke about
corned beef so there's part of me that
thinks gee it's wonderful that these
creative funny Jewish minds are doing
things are creative and funny and
calling them Jewish but there's another
part of me that mourns the loss of the
realization that you have made a deep
rich foundational tradition of Western
civilization into shtick and that's too
bad
why are you funny well the traditional
answers Jews are funny because in
oppression you don't have that many
outlets for hostility or even to
alleviate hostility and one of the
things about humour that I mean people
know is that if you feel something very
deeply even if it's pain and you make a
joke it makes it a little bit better I
read once that Nietzsche the philosopher
said that wit closes the coffin on an
emotion you feel something you don't
want to feel it you make a joke and it's
gone so there Jews have had to feel a
lot of things they didn't want to feel
yeah so neither I mean they're there we
could go through the list of them that's
part of it
forget the 50 greatest rabbis we goes
100 greatest comics no question probably
70 of them right would be Jewish
yes so if you think it's an athletic and
changing that huh as other immigrant
groups and this is the second part of it
which is the outsider also I think sees
so you get a different perspective of
the world if you're not ensconced in it
if you you know as the idea that some
whoever discovered water wasn't a fish
right you have to be somewhere outside
in order to see what what it is and the
outsider view is also a part of comedy
do you think Jesus sort of lost the cred
as the outsider because we've been sort
of hunted and hounded and I grew up
knowing gasps Holocaust survivors and
everything else and but now because you
have become depends where you are well I
think Jews and Beverly Hills aren't
outsiders but I think you go to Jews in
France even though they may be wealthy
or Jews in Hungary and they feel pretty
outside still and this is that this is
the genius and the wonder of America
that I think people don't appreciate
enough first of all any Jew who's not
who's American who isn't patriotic is an
idiot and doesn't know anything about
history or about their own about the
country or their own people but the
reason that America is so much better
for Jews is that it's not because
Americans are nicer than people
elsewhere and it's not because we have a
great Constitution because there are
other countries that have wonderful
constitutions and tyrannical governments
it's because elsewhere in the world you
had throughout history German
and Jews Hungarians and Jews Jews were
always the identifiable other in America
you don't have that in America what you
have is this salad of groups there are
Koreans and african-americans and Jews
and Hindus and Muslims and Protestants
and Catholics and on and on and on and
on thousands of groups so Jews had never
been the identifiable other it's not
like everybody got together and said oh
look there are Americans and Jews yeah
and so that's why yeah we don't have the
same sense of being Outsiders as we once
did but that's a good thing so I've a
couple times on this show mentioned
something about you know there's that
great line from Fiddler on the Roof
where you said some of the Debu society
to the effect of you know we're the
chosen people I just wish somebody money
out there I think a lot of Jews feel
that that feeling of wait a minute wait
is this whether you're a believer or not
believer say we're the chosen people the
right you look at the history of the
Jews from the Holocaust and pogroms and
being kicked out of virtually every
other country the amount of dwindling
Jews in France right now everything else
this is an odd how do you reconcile that
with a choice in so if you're actually
between people well I would say in fact
the it goes back to the answer that we
were just talking about which is if you
are the identifiable other and you
refuse to assimilate into the mainstream
then people will resent you and this is
not wouldn't that be a great argument
for just assimilating and you call me a
rap if you think that the whole world
should be the same and vanilla is the
only flavor yes but if you think that
the the proliferation of traditions is a
glory I would say glory to God but
certainly a glory to humanity then no
and I think that most of us would
believe that resisting being like
everybody else is inherently a good
thing even though for most of history it
was seen as a bad thing I think in case
Jews were right
and so in medieval times when they
didn't want to be Christian or they
didn't want to be Muslim despite the
fact that it was resented I think that
that's tremendous it costs them very
dearly and by the way over the
generations many
many many Jews did disappear so you have
populations of people all over the world
who have Jewish ancestry who have no
idea that they have Jewish ancestry
[Music]
you